a fã assim e aí galera que aceite meu
canal tudo com você e estarei pronto
essa semana o canal chegou a 30 milhões
de seguidores salvo por mim
se você faz parte desses 30 milhões se
você está seguindo há muito tempo se
você chegou agora já deixa o seu like aí
taques é muito importante porque gostei
muitas pessoas inventaram um outro vídeo
windows onde é isso que você está
gravando este é o seu cativeiro é aí
onde você leva suas vítimas só se mude
encaixam na caixa d'água que toda vez
que alguém gastar água em casa ela já
viu o motor já repõe aqui entendeu então
pelo tempo de reposição sei se a pessoa
tomou banho com esse calor pelo tempo e
foi bem rapidinho que foi só a descargas
encaro essa é a minha casa nova para
falar a verdade essa parte do que eu
estou é o só tem gente que confunde os
othon comporão não tem nada a ver o
porão é que a pessoa vá ao terremoto eo
furacão katrina todo o porão do sol você
vai contemplar unaca cpi que tem alma de
espírito seu plano só têm alguma alma
foi aparecer nessa casa com certeza vai
ser aqui que ele vai ver primeiro o
número dá toda vez que entro aqui pra
gravar vídeo primeiro santo anjo do
senhor muse guardador cm com seu apiário
divina sempre me redimi código velho me
a mim e aí você tem essa opção é
procurar uma casa com um porão e com um
só tom
só que eu preferi só também que aquele
terremoto trazendo terremoto furacão não
tem furacão equipe redimunho o redimunho
o negócio rodando no papel o menino eta
dentro do vídeo muito renda
aqui tem fumo pensando que vai encontrar
o saf ali dentro não tem porque eu
percebi quando eu mudei pra essa casa
nova que eu sou adulto que ela estava
resolvendo o assunto no banco tem noção
que está a pagar a conta no banco estão
conversando mais calorosa as taxas sobre
um adulto que eu tô nessa casa nova e me
tornei a pessoa que mais criticavam a
minha vida a minha mãe ou outra visita
que chega que eu apresenta casa todo
igual à mãe vem câmera de ver que os
quarto dia minha mãe que é o partido
estava no chão e que não deu tempo ainda
no que toca à comida no fogão eficaz
quando já os cachorros pega tudo que é o
partido das cachorro a copa do rei não
ou mulher o dia todinho que deu dado
menor carga de preguiças cachorro meu
deus estou ficando benfica olha só como
falava roupas um baby doll pintar meu
sonho de rebocar os cabelos de aracaju
afirmou anthony toda mãe pitadinha de
rua ou maçã do amor e
acabei de aracaju peta nova não é tem 52
anos pintou os cabelos de acaju pensa
que tem 26 e eu estou percebendo que
estão virando adulto cara ao todo a casa
nova também preocupam com cor diferente
estou virando a minha mãe eu não tenho
mais paciência para a conta estava
jogando futevôlei que agora eu joguei
nem papai jogos a filme foi levantar a
bola jogou perdeu o nome você só vê como
eu estava puto porque caiu uma terra de
novo eu tô até hoje de manhã com essa
desgraça que eu sei que tá aqui ó tentou
saber que se está aqui e tá aqui ó
eu não tá aqui e tá aqui ó paí ó é os
integral usando as imensas a merda não
tenho paciência não tenho disposição vai
para as coisas chegam no lugar que tem
piscina mas aumentar na piscina ea
cabeça comece a processar [ __ ] merda vou
ter que estar na piscina gelada essa
meta não vou aguentar vou ter que sair
vou sair tem que se julgar ainda é
possível julgar pequeno banho que o povo
indígena por na piscina do kbw sai sujo
não tende a responder não ficar só que
na beirada mesmo é só os pé eu ficar ali
enchendo o saturn em que miro sim tem
disposição um piscinão amigo criança
quando viu a piscina ela entra 7 horas
da manhã sai meia-noite hora pode não
saber nadar
ela fica assim embora brincado pega-pega
não me pega
após sair da piscina de noite parece o
velho 85 armam tudo em geada nós botando
medo mineiro é isso ai mas não vai ficar
sem graça né não
é um carro mão de ver mas é uma mulher
miguel mãe me ligou pra command velho e
vai ficar sem volta mas não ficou com
medo minha diversão está na piscina ou
no mar
agora quando me empurra na piscina eu
fico quem também voltou a dar trabalho
pra sair adultos saem de piscinas por
mais discreta que tem da criança ela vem
na banda sai por é só comendo adulto
fica parecendo um cachorro treinado por
jorginho o tamanho g mendes bota o pé
pra cima e queen e agora tem um dia
desses eu estava assistindo filme eu vi
como eu tinha virado adulto mesmo de
verdade ou seja no filme a cena mais
linda do mundo era um pai que estava
brigado com a filha do nada eles fizeram
as pazes a então lamarca conversando
começa a fazer guerra de travesseiro
como essa foi a pena pra todo lado e
batem as pernas voando a cena
emocionante uma trilha linda cohama
ainda que tem no mundo olha assim dizer
meu deus é um tem que arrumar sistema
tudim depois nesse oita merda de si ou
horta sintoma ataque o tabu tá aqui ó
eu sinto grosa eu falo assim eu citei
groso dessa merda cisco de merda que
ficar aturando todo mundo pergunta no
outro sabor que ficou sandro neto filho
aqui sentindo negócio fica usando aqui
ele fica vermelho rebaixem menininho por
é maconha né amigo é fumar maconha só
com oito selecionado pega pega uma coisa
aqui ó
sob esse lado aqui ó eu ficar vermelho
burros e ficado na briga diferente eu
aparecer no buggy hair doença na
argentina é pura casa e fazer um exame
que dá luiza aqui em casa eu falei vou
fazer também disse que está com gordura
no fígado ea mulher - você saber que
você tem gordura no fígado dela dizer
sabia que eu use pique atrás eu abro eu
pego ele é fisher mallandro está salgado
é bom saber disso isso é mais criança
não é um adulto por o nível de gordura
que está aqui nesse exame aqui a bem
pertinho é parte da hepatite com câncer
2 palitinho amigo e minha mulher
trancou que não passava o cache coach
fazer o quê dieta que é uma coisa que
quem faz adulto nunca ouvi uma pessoa
dizer se for criança tome a fiac a
recarga nem daniela responderam da união
está cortando fazendo mal ao menino não
cada dia tenho mais convicção que
ouviram nada estou fazendo as contas o
diz é verdade vocês e eu quando eu
comecei a fazer tudo comecei a fazer
show é estourado era estourado fazer
show voltar pra casa passar na frente da
loja assim no aeroporto os relógios
bonito disse antónio guterres relógio
que cara meu dente era assim quando eu
comecei eu deixei o coitado toneladas
nec chama acontece relógio e cara olha
pra mim falar o senhor cinchetto na
faixa de mais ou menos 3.500 é isso aí
cabo diziam isto é tudo tão 3 mil reais
no relógio publiada preocupa que a fauna
marinha pb 393 voltar aqui o pescoço
pronto estou fazendo as contas para o
paredes é besta luís decidiu viajar
afirmou compra cafeteira tempo na casa
nova e faltam algumas coisas na compra
cafeteira de fazer um cafezinho el
viajero ele me ligou falou amorim
comprar quarteto pediu só conseguinte a
caf tem aqui é 400 reais quer que eu
faço diz faça suco e eu vim pra evitar
400 e arrancar pt
aí vocês e as escola próxima de e-mail e
quatrocentos reais
tá achando muito curto de um jato filha
da [ __ ] é amigo do neymar não isso te
causei
agora tu quer dizer 1010 meteu por neuer
é por isso que eu tenho as coisas que
não se gasta dinheiro com cafeteira de
400 reais quando todo mundo gosta do
documento merda pra comprar um negócio
que faz café e 481 god café maçã 2 400
ea de café
agora estou fazendo contou guardando e
eu penso na minha vida agora o ps se eu
tiver um filho hoje tem dinheiro e
amanhã porque meu irmão se um dia eu
ficar pobre paulo meu curso já fui pobre
não quis aprender não pode descarregar
uma reunião de sal da minha escola eu
saco de sal nas costas no sol quente o
salar bernabéu me senti um sapo a ação o
cortador de grama descarregar brita de
aba cota eu já fui então eu sei agora se
eu tiver um filho comigo vai nascer que
tudo muito melhor
aí o
o meu o menino acostumada terrier fica
pobre vira um imbecil idiota em um ponto
na escola o meu pai me deu 12 e 18 na
próxima férias a gente vai buscar ir no
meu melhor amigo é o mickey mouse até 10
late sabe dele então quero trabalhar
fazer esse dinheiro crescer pelo dar o
meu filho a opção de escolha pelo tipo
eu já passei nem três meses deram na
universidade federal ainda paga não só
que eu passei em teresina eu não tinha
como manter um aluguel caro então não
fica não tinha escolha você quiser
assistir deve ser uma pessoa estudava e
era um advogado um dinheiro um alguma
coisa e fica falando que esse babaca
ganha mais dinheiro que o porquê esse
babaca imbecil fez um cabelo que ele
insiste em deixar crescer que pensa que
é bonito a barba eo cabelo de preto ele
bota disse que este bebê fica pensando
que é uma pessoa mais máscula do mundo
nunca termina a bosta dessa tatuagem que
tem pegava na porta do cativeiro a
desgraça com a merda do agogô pro eu tô
aqui assistindo ele tem milhões de views
e testar porque que saibam 70 desses
meninos a bosta que assinar uma merda
que o brasileiro espera o brasileiro
gosto de pega merda e votá lá em cima né
e quem precisa valorizar noé porque esse
merda porque esse bosta
aí eu tô aqui sabe porque não tinha
opção de escolha que iria fazer
universidade eu queria me forma eu
queria ter um diploma mas eu não tinha
como eu não tinha opção de escolha você
pensa ou ruins então hoje você já tem
dinheiro e quer fazer faculdade e se
formar
olhando para o meu mundo que estava há
amor demais mas eu quero que meus filhos
têm a opção de escolha
eu quero que se um dia meu filho tiver
no meio do período ele diga sim papai eu
não quero mais ser engenheiro não quero
fazer artes cênicas do cisne são
espetáculos só pra cisne mercado bom
caminho e eu vou dizer faça honra só
porque porque se você quiser fazer que
se alarga que vai fazer outra que 20 ano
eu tenho dinheiro para bancar eu quero
que minha filha falar se o papai não
quero mais fazer direito não é isso que
eu encontrei estou aqui há um ano e meio
e eu não curtir quer fazer balé quero me
formar balé eu quero ser a maior parte
de ballet de londres minha filha os seus
sonhos que se quer falar não porque eu
vou estar dando a ele a opção de
escolher o que eu fiz foi atrás de
vesti meu dinheiro e poder aprender a
investir fazer o dinheiro trabalhar por
mim enquanto eu trabalho também sabe o
que eu fiz isso eu já fui em casa de
artistas que não vai televisão tem dez
anos que não faz show tem dez anos
lançou a música tem 10 anos e não faz um
filme tem dez anos ea casa maior do
mundo a sua barriga do mundo tudo do bom
e do melhor todo mundo vivendo bem
porque que ganhou muito dinheiro e
investir e hoje que as coisas não
precisa ficar se matando em cima milhão
de fazer nada ninguém fala na hora que
quero dizer que quer né então fui
pesquisar sobre investimento e eu
descobri o canal do primo rico é essa
aqui está um receio da por investir
porque quando você fala investimento na
cabeça de quem está ouvindo país quer
meu deus tem que ser um milhão de reais
para poder investir se não não eu
descobri que dá para investir r$30 00
cinquenta reais pra cima se consegue
investir que eu sei que há muita gente
faz muita diferença 30 a 50 reais 30
condenados um lanche numa pizza é um
negócio que se você poupar você vai
investir lá no canal do porto rico a
gente gravou um vídeo eu investiria lhe
ensinando a investir primeiro na
descrição do vídeo você pode conferir a
assistir o vídeo lá que pelo menos esse
cara que ouve do canal nunca vi na minha
vida não sabia quem era ninguém nunca me
falou sobre ele eu achei porque eu
pesquisei e o cara está com a vida feita
tudo porque soube investir no momento
certo se você gostou desse vídeo esquece
aplicarem gostei está aqui não esquece
eu queria que você comentasse aqui
embaixo qual é o seu sonho a meu sonho é
morar em outro país sabe o sonho é me
formar para tirar meus pais da casa que
ele mora e botar uma casa melhor eu
quero levar meu filho para a disney quer
fazer o seu que eu queria saber eu
queria ler os comentários dos e sabem
quais são sobre você e eu como ex
corintiano é bom eu que o meu sonho
quando era criança para comer um campino
do cantor acredita nisso eu vi na
televisão a propaganda que a sandy e
júnior fazia e eu ficava cara queria um
dia comum campino 22 50 camp nou o meu
pai não tinha condição de comprar eu
cresci ganhe dinheiro comprei o capítulo
depois meu sonho é evoluir já tem uma
família ea família precisou a casa não
tá minha família e eu tenho hoje a minha
casa e hoje meu sonho subiu mais ainda é
ver um filho ou uma filha minha sei lá
realizado naquele que ele quis fazer
então é isso tamo junto obrigados a
assistir esse vídeo até aqui dizer que
estou muito feliz e também no youtube
casa nova a tv pra gravar vídeo espero
que vocês continuem aí comigo
o tempo que tudo dê certo a vida de
vocês algo junto é nóis em buffy to
carnes clicar em agosto esse número é
chato sufocar